hey everyone at seven my office is a big
mess right now and the reason is I took
apart my bookcase and i was looking at
all the books i had if you guys have
watched videos before you know that
usually back here i have this big
bookcase full of all the books that i
have and i kept looking at the bookcase
in thinking you know i haven't read most
of these or if I have it hasn't been for
a really long time I've never gone back
to them why are they still here and then
I started to feel guilty I felt like I
should really read these books right I
should spend half an hour night and
dedicate that time to reading the books
so what I've done is I've taking them
off my bookcase and they are now sitting
here on my desk in this huge pile and
the refocus here I'm trying to shoot
left-handed whoa zooming in let's zoom
back out there we go so tons of these
books that I you know you again have it
right for a long time or if I have I'm
not going back to them and I wanted to
gather that guilty zone right I felt
like I should have I should be reading
these but I'm not and then I realized
not to do it just because I feel like I
should if I haven't gone back to these
books I have it open them up there's a
reason and my busy day is busy enough I
don't want to add more stress to it and
so I'm going to give these books away of
all the books that i have i've saved
seven of them so i'm i'm getting rid of
all these are going to the library
they're gonna go find a new home and
i'll walk over here to the rest of my
office and there are seven books are six
years i've listed but there are seven
books that I'm keeping if you want to
know more about these books and why I'm
keeping them I can make another video
let me know in the comments below but
they all have some kind of meaning to me
either personal meaning or there's still
some business advice I'll like getting
from them but I guess you know we all
have this clutter in our lives right at
least for me if my life is cluttered my
business is cluttered I'm not focused I
get distracted and so is I feel so much
better now having made that decision
that you're rid of these books and also
don't do things because you feel you
should do it do it because there's a
reason
you have a strong passion for it or it's
going to help somebody so that's my
quick story hope you guys enjoy you know
the drill give it a like below if you
like the video and I want to hear from
you leave a comment below thank you will
see you soon